hey leute was gehabt und damit herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einem neuen video
ist irgendwie raus für seine
comicfiguren dass ich irgendwie so weiß
ich nicht das t shirt ist mir ein
bisschen kleiner scheißegal herzlich
willkommen zur endlich vierten folge
meines geld experiment ist ich weiß
einige zeit ist jetzt nicht so kommen
jetzt wieder mitbekommen es hat sich ein
bisschen was verändern in meinem leben
deswegen habe ich kein neues cooles
projekt gefunden was jetzt konkret super
in dieses format gepasst hätte aber ich
habe das ganze natürlich nicht vergessen
und deswegen sitze ich heute hier und
bin mal gespannt wie es nach diesem
video so ausschaut das cool ist wir
haben keinen sponsor partner aber ich
habe auch eine geile idee womit ich
wieder ein bisschen geld verdienen kann
ein kollege von mir der handelt nämlich
mit speziell auch mit der seiner schule
und die bekommen wirklich zu extrem
günstigen konditionen ganz ganz viele
schuhe einfach mal so viele kaufen und
der meinte alex kammer vorbei ich glaube
uns ein paar schuhe abwehr ist so
fertigmachen die schau mal was du so
viele dabei sind kauft die dann ab und
versucht ihr dann irgendwie loszuwerden
er meinte dass wir zeit funktionieren
wenn nicht bin ich dumm deswegen hoffe
ich mal dass das so stimmt wobei ein
bisschen dumm bin ich halt manchmal ich
habe morgen nachmittag ein termin bei
dem dann fahren wir dahin für mich geht
es jetzt erst mal nach hause dann freue
ich mich auf morgen weil ich hoffe
morgen werde erfolgreicher tag wir sehen
wieso leute was geht ab wunderschönen
guten morgen für mich geht's auf jeden
fall erstmal ab ins büro kurz vorweg
noch mega ice gestern abend ist endlich
der lkw keyboard thema angekommen ihr
wisst es mit adwords arbeite ich schon
lange zusammen saugroboter mit vielen
neuen funktionen ich hab mir gestern
installiert wir fahren jetzt allerdings
ins büro ich kann natürlich von überall
aus steuern er hat eine kamera
integriert und dann haben wir was
richtig leiste es vor also heute bewegen
wir uns in big steps zum auto und ich
glaube nach diesem video sind wir
fünfstellig
ich habe dem trainer
installiert gestern ich habe die
ladestation angebracht und so weiter und
so fort jetzt habe ich den gerade mal
gestartet so sieht das bis jetzt aus der
baut sich quasi gerade mein zuhause auf
das wird perfekt abgelagert abgemessen
und dann hast du irgendwann wie beim
einem anderen gerät wobei das hier noch
die alte ansicht ist so eine komplette
map mit allen zimmern allen räumen und
das geil ist bei dem 49 wie also bei dem
neuen dingen von mir wir können sogar in
den videomodus gehen und jetzt check um
schaut mal hier die kammer jetzt einfach
sehen was bei ihm so geht er sucht sie
jetzt gerade in den weg kommt da ein
bisschen auf theoretisch wenn ich jetzt
hier darauf drückte kann ich sogar hallo
reden was ich auch noch super geil
finden bei dem tenor wir haben so neue
reinigungsbürste es war mal ein bisschen
nervig oft haben sich ladekabel oder
sonst was darin verfangen das kann jetzt
nicht mehr passieren das ist ein
unfassbarer vorteil das ist teils echt
cool wir haben eine vision funktion der
saugt extrem stark also damit macht ihr
kein versteck gern mal den link in der
baubeschreibung ab und soll sich das mal
an so und wir müssen jetzt geld verdient
so leute und was natürlich auch noch
ganz wichtiges wir stehen aktuell bei
4100 irgendwas ich muss euch ein wenn
plus noch die werbeeinnahmen von geld
experiment drei das zählt ja auch dazu
die blende ich euch auch einmal hier ein
ich glaube dass müssten 300 oder 400
euro sein was natürlich auch einiges ist
deswegen sind wir zum schluss jetzt die
schuhe habe ich für 500 oder werde ich
bestimmt kaufen sind doch wieder bei
viereinhalb jetzt nur grob überschlagen
und dann muss ich sie los werden und
dann bin ich mal gespannt wo wir dann
laden bloß auf die nette video
integration von access wird nice okay
jetzt muss ich natürlich kann man aber
die polizei halo ist nur ist kein handys
kamera ich bin echt mal gespannt wie
viel wir dann in der fünften folge haben
er leiter ich bin halb so leute
angekommen jetzt gehe ich mal hier rein
mal gucken was da so auf mich wartet ich
bin gespannt so leute was gedacht ich
bin jetzt hier mittlerweile in eurem
schul lager angekommen das geht erst mal
dass josef übrigens leistete sich kommen
durfte das wäre auf jeden fall muss man
sagen ihr habt hier einige schuhe ganz
viele verschiedene marken auf oder also
eigentlich alles was ist jetzt beginnt
ja auch ich mal war und du weißt doch
mal was ich mache und ich dachte mir so
als nächsten step ich kaufe ich jetzt
für du machst mir geile geile sammlung
ich komme ich geb dir 500 euro und wo
gehst du einfach schuhe mit alles
mögliche macht richtig geile show bezirk
und dann schauen wir mal du sagst also
ich kann das jetzt selbst gut verkaufen
oder also prozent also ist top qualität
und
ok ich hab schon viel gesehen diesen
leandro lopez kenne ich wir haben hier
so viele schuhe habt ihr schon zu aufs
cover und auch viel zu viel so moody's
natürlich das ist
das ist auch gut passt auf wir gehen
jetzt rum du kannst bisschen zeigen und
dann nehme ich das mit
kompressor manchmal was ist das hier das
hat es mir von dem ins auge schon
sind die gut habe ich davon ein paar
mitnehmen ok dann reicht es nicht was du
möchtest okay das ist was du das nehme
ich schon mal
schnell darauf nämlich welche schuhgröße
wir brauchen hier habe ich auch ihm
gehört das sind auch so typisch deutsche
mutter shue
kann man immer tragen jetzt mal hier so
als beispiel das ist ja schon schuh der
ist ja nicht günstig was kostet er so
wenn man den jetzt neu kauft dieser
schule man den neukauf kostet 130 euro
160 und wenn ich jetzt
hab ich auch das
bleibt mein einig dass viele geben was
gibt mir dunkelblau noch von denen ja
auch kommt da gibt es ja noch die rote
übertragen nein nein das reicht erstmal
guck mal ich stelle diesmal schon mal
hier ab das sind jetzt wohl ihn war es
30 wenn du mit dem preis macht sie mit
diesem
123456 was wäre das so pi mal daumen
überschlagen für dich 200 ja ok oder für
dich jetzt habe ich das ja schon wenn es
mit dem hier wieder raus mit dem
aber ihr habt ja so viele von deswegen
rechnet sich das für mich ne also ich
sehe jetzt keinen ab oder sie kaufen
viel ein zu einem guten preis auf jeden
fall man muss ja auch schon sagen wenn
jetzt ein großkunde kommt der direkt 30
40 paar schuhe mitnehmen oder vielleicht
auch sogar krieg der 500
dann ist das ähnlich der preis so
deswegen leute alles gut ja ein paar
nehme ich noch hier extra noch geld
abgehoben
dass ich ihn gut lagers
diesem gold ich denke ich meine die
verkaufe ich meine mama jetzt zu
weihnachten jetzt vor allem da kann man
schöne geschenk gehört donner carolina
hermann hier
sonst gibt mir auch gerne wenn ihr jetzt
von irgend ein paar viele habt gebt mir
ruhig fünf gleiche das ist finde ich
auch gut zum beispiel die ihr was ist
das die von sora volina ja leute die
nehme ich jetzt auch noch mit dann suche
ich mir noch ein paar aus und ich glaube
für euch sehen wir uns dann gleich
wieder wenn ich zu hause bin und die
allemal aus punk und dann richtig mal
zusammen das ist ja so eine verlieren
kann wenn jetzt leute von meinen
zuschauer interessiert sind für hier mal
vorbeizuschauen oder euch mal zu
kontaktieren wir machen jetzt am besten
leisten wir unsere instagram seite oder
e mail also wir sind da sehr breit
gestreut und man kann uns auf jeden fall
erreichen die e mail werde nicht durch
hier mal ein danke dass ich vorbei
kommen durfte so was die dort schon gut
aus leute was geht ab wir haben gerade
abend heute ist der tag wo ich alle
schuhe geordnet habe und die einmal
zusammengerechnet habe und leute wir
haben wirklich ich habe es auf meinem
rechner nicht gelöscht das sind hier
meine top schuhe von den weißen habe ich
sogar zwei mitgenommen die kosten
einfach im internet 390 euro die blauen
habe ich für 250 gesehen und die roten
auch für 300 wobei wer gibt dafür jetzt
doch 300 euro aus also da bin ich
wirklich spannend für was direkt in die
2300 euro 80 sind so die wenigsten
preise für alle schuhe die ich halt
zusammen habt was unfassbar vieles mehr
das muss man sagen ich werde ja safe
dass dafür nicht bekommen also niemals
mal so lange ich nur die hälfte davon
bekomme ist das ja schon geil ich habe
alle schon einmal bei instagram bei mir
gepostet und die top dinge habe ich auch
ins internet gestellt und 3 habe ich
sogar schon verkauft also wir haben
jetzt schon muss ich morgen noch mal
durchrechnen ich schicke die auch
morgens schon los aber auf jeden fall
über 300 euro verliehen weil ich auch
zweimal leandro lópez verkauft habe was
auf jeden fall wirklich super ist wir
sehen uns morgen noch mal wieder und
dann zeige ich euch ein bisschen mehr
noch wünsche mir weiterhin wurde was
geht wir haben eine weile freitag wieso
habe ich am dienstag abgeholt natürlich
muss man auch ein bisschen zeit
einfahren ist ja klar wir haben jetzt
insgesamt wir stehen doch 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
die muss ich jetzt länger zur post
bringen sie lernen wo lopez habe ich
alle über insta verkauft das ist
eigentlich ganz gut für mich schnell
dann habe ich zum ersten mal auch so
überwindet verkauft das ist ja so eine
seite und ein paar über ebay
kleinanzeigen und jetzt habe ich hier
noch elf paarungen stehen ich weiß auf
jeden fall erstmal zur post und kann ich
aber sagen dass ich gerade mit meinem
kollegen von denen ich die schuhe
gekauft haben würde ich nämlich gern ein
paar wieder zurück bringen weil ich die
nicht los werden also zum beispiel die
hier von diesen habe ich halt zwei paar
so die kosten auch nicht viel und da hat
sich niemand für interessiert oder diese
fehler stiefelt dann kann ich auch
verstehen warum die keiner haben will
zwei paar damals habe ich noch eine
freundin verkauft für was waren das 105
euro glaube ich war immer lernen hob ist
und weiß wie weit 150 dann einmal ein
blauer einmal ein rot 420 ich bin durch
meine liste ein für was die alles weg
gegangen sind und man muss sagen ich
bekomme 150 euro noch wieder für die
restlichen neuen park nicht verkauft hat
das heißt wir lernen es dann bei
1000 haben hier 1130 euro also 630 euro
gewinnen das ist echt gut so ab zur post
sollte das gut ist ich habe so eine der
stationen direkt bei mir um die ecke
aber ich bin so froh wenn diese ganzen
schule endlich wieder wechselte das ist
ja meine leute ein paket genau um die
schweiz das hat einfach wieder 17 eur 70
gekostet ich hoffe das kommt überhaupt
an dass er nämlich sonst ein bisschen
ärgerlich na ich habe es geschafft das
ist schon mal gut alles ist weg bzw das
meiste hier seht ihr immer nur hier so
das fertige video aber da steckt immer
eine menge arbeit hinter das alles sind
weg zu bringen und so hallo da habe ich
einige zeit investiert trotzdem optics
gelohnt und beim nächsten mal sage ich
euch doch mal den betrag den wir haben
der wird nämlich echt ganz gut sein und
wir werden dann schon ein bisschen mehr
als ein drittel von dem endbetrag die
ich dann irgendwann brauche zusammen
haben ich hoffe es hat euch hingefallen
das super gerne mal um dann abonniert
den kanal wenn ihr weitere teile des
experiments nicht verpassen wollt dann
würde ich mich auf jeden fall super
darüber freuen und wenn ihr ideen habt
was ich noch so machen kann um mein geld
zu vermehren dann schreibt auf jeden
fall in die kommentare dann hast du
schon heute haut rein